Everybody can agree,
especially in England,
uh,
that this was a crisis whereas the made
in USA label and a,
that we export it or toxic mortgages,
uh,
that,
in fact we send a thank you note all the
time to your for buying so many of our
toxic mortgages.
We sold about 40 percent of them to
Europe and,
uh,
it had it not been for that the downturn
in the US would have been much worse.
There were three parts of the response.
The first was a stimulus and when Obama
got elected,
it was good that he finally got around
to it.
Bush didn't,
didn't do anything about this,
but it was too small and it was not well
designed.
We're not going to be out of this crisis
very quickly.
One of the things that will be emerging
out of this crisis is realization of
countries that have bigger reserves did
better.
So there'll be an even greater demand
for savings.
Net will get reduce global aggregate
demand.
You have failed really to reform our
global economic system.
We have failed to reform a regulatory
system,
failed to provide the kind of economic
system that would provide stability and
security,
and the result would add is that,
uh,
these economic weaknesses are going to
persist.
Do you think the American tax payer has
been ripped off in essence by the band
out of the American taxpayer,
very clear,
got treated very badly.
The typical pattern in the chaos of a
crisis.
Uh,
the bankers who caused the crisis than
steal money massively because people
aren't noticing that.
And I said,
Oh God,
this is going to happen again in the
United States.
I hoped that we had better institutions,
but what it turned out is that we had
better mechanism for theft.
It's such an elementary issue of
incentives.
If you're too big to fail,
then you have incentive to gamble
because if you gamble and when you walk
off with the prophets,
even gamble and lose,
the government picks up the tab a why
not gamble?
I think the UK did a much,
much better in three ways.
First,
uh,
you,
you had some sense of accountability
that you,
some of the ceos had to go.
Secondly,
you put some conditions,
we didn't put any condition,
so we allow the money to pour in and
pour out and we gave the story that we
had to recapitalize the banks in order
to help them land.
But if money is pouring in and pouring,
oh,
that's not recapitalizing the banks.
Thirdly,
you tried a wasn't totally successful,
but you understood you wanted the banks
to start lending and you try to get some
incentives,
some institutional reforms to get the
banks to land the criticism,
the somewhere I work that I don't
understand.
You know,
I,
I very good at identifying a market
failure,
but I'm a little bit less students in
and talking about government failure.
Uh,
let me say that anybody in America lived
through the Bush administration,
understands government failure.
We have to think much more carefully
about how we spend money.
So I'm very critical of the hundreds of
billions of dollars that we spend in the
United States.
Um,
weapons that don't work against enemies
that don't exist.
Um,
we get neither security nor economic
growth.
So that seems to me a,
a good target for cutting.
And we disagree allocating that money to
investments that will lead to higher
growth and therefore lower a national
debt in the long run.